well it was bound to happen eventually
the rise of Skywalker rumour mill has
finally turned out a genuine gut punch
read it's User Jedi praxis it claims to
be close to the film's production has
been busily leaking what they claim to
be the entire plot of the film over the
last month or so their latest revelation
has to do if c-3po and if it's got any
truth to it it seems that more than a
few fans hearts are going to be broken
into pieces of course it's important to
point out that this report has but in no
way confirmed the rumors around the
rights of Skywalker have been flying
fast and furious of late and nothing
substantial has come from any official
sources of backup Jedi paksas leaks that
said there are ports offered up by Jedi
pack sis carry an air of legitimacy for
one compelling reason several of the
plot points which they have put forward
have been verified by Star Wars fan
sites who each cite their own
independent sources Bespin bulletin and
Jason Ward of making Star Wars comm have
both corroborated specific elements of
July packs s reports so there's a good
chance some of these leaks contain at
least some accurate information it
should also be mentioned that the rise
of Skywalker is currently in the midst
of reshoots so some of the plot details
that are being reported on at this time
could easily change by the time the
final Kurt's theaters having said all
that do be aware potentially huge
spoilers for the rights of Skywalker lay
ahead this particular rumor revolves
around the mysterious dagger which was
once owned by a forced user
loyal to the set and upon it has
inscribed a message in an identifiable
language during the course of the film
Rey Poe and Finn are led to believe that
this dagger may be the key to locating a
Wayfinder a device up for plot reasons
as desperately sought after by both the
movies heroes and villains letting a
long story short has to do with this guy
right here
luckily the heroes are able to locate
the dagger but c-3po
despite being fluent at over six million
forms of communication can only identify
the inscription as an ancient set
language one of which he cannot
translate due to restrictions in his
programming Finn Rey and Poe
subsequently enlists the aid of an old
acquaintance of Poe's names Ori blessed
to track down someone capable of hacking
the protocol droids programming thus
allowing him to provide a translation
they're able to do so but there's a
catch and this is a pretty significant
catch to always contact informs ray Poe
and Finn that he can get them to do what
they want but if he does
c-3po s memory will be completely wiped
understandably the heroes are reluctant
to lose a faithful companion but this is
where c-3po finally gets his moment
the spotlight the Droid insists that a
procedure be carried out knowing full
well that for all intents and purposes
it will lead to his death
szura's contact does his thing and the
modification results in a new of bread
I'd look for Threepio as seen in the d23
trailer that debuted earlier this year
the droid is then able to read the
daggers inscription which reveals the
location of the wayfinder once his task
is complete c-3po reboots and after that
happens he said longer the droid he once
was instead now little more than a blank
slate it's worth noting that c-3po has
appeared in every single Star Wars film
save for solo a Star Wars story it's
also safe to say that he's been more
prone to cowardice and heroism during
that time but if the rise of Skywalker's
be the character's last on-screen
appearance which it almost certainly is
it seems apt to finally give this iconic
protocol droid a genuine moment of
heroic self-sacrifice check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]